BRETT KAVANAUGH FIRING BACK
AGAINST SEXUAL MISCONDUCT
ALLEGATIONS IN AN EXCLUSIVE
INTERVIEW WITH FOX NEWS.
YOU WILL HEAR FROM HIM IN A
MOMENT.
BUT FIRST, WE WANT TO GET YOU
CAUGHT UP.
THE SUPREME COURT NOMINEE
BLASTING WHAT HE IS CALLING A
LAST MINUTE CHARACTER
ASSASSINATION WHILE ADDING HE
WON’T BE SMEARED AND
INTIMIDATED INTO
WITHDRAWALLING.
THIS COMES AS A SECOND ACCUSER
HAS COME FORWARD ACCUSING
KAVANAUGH OF SEXUAL MISCONDUCT
DURING A PARTY WHEN THEY WERE
STUDENTS AT YALE.
THE WOMAN IDENTIFIED AS DEBBIE
RAMIREZ IS ADMITTING TO "THE
NEW YORKER" SHE IS NOT CERTAIN
IT WAS KAVANAUGH AT FIRST AND
ACKNOWLEDGES THERE ARE GAPS IN
HER MEMORY OF THE EVENING
BECAUSE SHE WAS DRINKING.
THE AUTHOR WHO COWROTE THE
PIECE EXPLAINS MORE ABOUT THE
UNCORROBORATED CLAIMS.
>> AT FIRST SHE WASN’T SURE IT
WAS KAVANAUGH, WHEN YOU FIRST
CAME TO HER LAST WEEK.
YOU WRITE AFTER SIX DAYS OF
MEMORIES AND CONSULTING CONSULTN
MEMORIES AND CONSULTING CONSULTG
MEMORIES AND CONSULTING CONSULTW
MEMORIES AND CONSULTING CONSULTT
CAREFULLY ASSESSING HER
MEMORIES AND CONSULTING CONSULTH
HER ATTORNEY SHE BECAME
CONFIDENT IT WAS HIM.
>> GEORGE, THAT IS EXTREMELY
TYPICAL OF THE STORIES.
WHEN YOU ARE DEALING WITH
TRAUMA, ALCOHOL, MANY YEARS IN
BETWEEN.
I THINK THE MORE CAUTIOUS
WITNESSES I HAVE DEALT WITH IN
CASES LIKE THIS, VERY
FREQUENTLY SAY, "I WANT TO
TAKE TIME TO DECIDE, I WANT TO
TALK TO OTHER PEOPLE INVOLVED.
I WANT TO SEARCH MYSELF AND
MAKE SURE THAT I CAN
AFFIRMATIVELY STAND BY THE
CLAIMS."
>> Jesse: FARROW CAUSING
CONTROVERSY WHEN EXPLAINING
WHY MS. RAMIREZ DECIDED TO
SPEAK OUT NOW.
>> SHE CAME FORWARD BECAUSE
SENATE DEMOCRATS BEGAN LOOKING
AT THE CLAIM.
THIS CAME TO THE ATTENTION OF
PEOPLE ON THE HILLED
INDEPENDENTLY.
IT HAS CORNERED HER TO AWKWARD
POSITION.
SHE TOOK TIME TO TO THINK
ABOUT IT CAREFULLY.
SHE SAID, "I DON’T WANT TO
RUIN ANYBODY’S LIFE" BUT SHE
FEELS THIS IS A SERIOUS CLAIM
AND CONSIDERS HER MEMORIES
CREDIBLE AND FELT SHE WAS
FORCED TO TELL HER STORY.
>> Jesse: THIS IS WHAT WAS
SAID IN THE EXCLUSIVE
INTERVIEW MARTHA MacCALLUM
TONIGHT.
>> THE TRUTH IS I HAVE NEVER
ASSAULTED ANYONE IN HIGH
SCHOOL OR OTHERWISE.
I AM NOT QUESTIONING OR HAVE
NOT QUESTIONED THAT PERHAPS
DR. FORD WAS SEXUALLY
ASSAULTED AT SOME POINT AT ANY
POINT IN SOME PLACE BUT I KNOW
I HAVE NEVER SEXUAL ASSAULTED
ANYONE.
>> Jesse: WHAT DO YOU THINK
OF THE PROCESS OF WHICH THE
WOMAN’S STORY CAME OUT?
SHE IS REACHED BY THE SENATE
DEMOCRAT STAFFERS AND THEN, I
BELIEVE, MAYBE SHE IS COACHED
OR MASSAGED BY LAWYERS AND
DEMOCRAT ACTIVISTS TO
REMEMBERING WHAT SHE BELIEVES
WAS A SEXUAL MISCONDUCT
SITUATION, ABOUT 35 YEARS AGO.
DOES THAT STRIKE YOU AS
STRANGE AT ALL?
>> YOU KNOW WHAT STRIKES ME AT
STRANGE THAT YOU HAVE FARROW
WHO HAD A GOOD REPUTATION, WHO
NOW COMES OUT AND SAYS WELL,
YOU KNOW, BASED ON MY
EXPERIENCE, IT’S NOT UNUSUAL
TO SEE WHAT HAS HAPPENED.
YOU’RE WRONG.
BASED ON MY EXPERIENCE, 35
YEARS IN LAW ENFORCEMENT,
CREATING A SEX CRIMES UNIT,
TRYING RAPE CASES, LISTENING
TO COMPLAINTS YOU DON’T HAVE
SOMEONE SAY I NEED SIX DAYS TO
FIGURE OUT WHO IT WAS.
AND THEN NEEDS TO CONSULT WITH
THEIR ATTORNEY.
THEY USUALLY AT THAT POINT IF
THEY BELIEVE THAT THERE WAS
SOME KIND OF SEXUAL ASSAULT OR
MISCONDUCT, THEY KNOW WHO DID
IT.
AND THE SIX DAYS ARE TO DECIDE
WHETHER OR NOT THEY WANT TO GO
OUT AND TELL THE STORY.
SHE SAYS SHE CAME OUT WITH IT
BECAUSE SHE WANTED TO TELL HER
STORY BEFORE SOMEONE ELSE
DOES.
THE BOTTOM LINE.
IF YOU CAN’T FIND A
CORROBORATING WITNESS TO
CONFIRM WHAT YOU ARE ALLEGING
WITH JUDGE KAVANAUGH WHO ELSE
ARE YOU WORRIED ABOUT TELLING
YOUR STORY BECAUSE THERE IS NO
STORY.
BUT I CAN START WITH DUE
PROCESS.
NOWHERE NEAR THE DELAYED
DEMOCRAT COMPLAINTS.
>> Jesse: SO JUAN, IF YOU
HAVE NO WITNESSES TO THE
ALLEGED MISCONDUCT AND THEN
YOU WERE CALLING AROUND SOME
OF YOUR FRIENDS BACK AT YALE
ON THE PHONE AND SAYING, "YOU
KNOW WHAT?
IT MAY HAVE BEEN KAVANAUGH, IT
MAY NOT HAVE BEEN KAVANAUGH.
DO YOU THINK IT WAS KAVANAUGH?
I CAN’T QUITE REMEMBER."
THEN ANOTHER FEMALE ASSOCIATE,
HER BEST FRIEND SAYS SHE NEVER
TOLD ME ANYTHING ABOUT THIS.
DOES THIS TELL YOU THAT MAYBE
SHE MIGHT NOT HAVE IT EXACTLY
RIGHT ABOUT SPECIFICALLY
KAVANAUGH?
>> Juan: YEAH, IT DOES.
I THINK THAT SHE IS SAYING OF
HER OWN VOLITION SHE WANTS TO
BE SURE.
THAT SHE THINKS IT’S SUCH A
SERIOUS ALLEGATION SHE TOOK
TIME AND SHE IS PUTTING ALL OF
YOUR DOUBTS OUT IN PUBLIC.
SHE IS NOT TRYING TO SAY OH,
I’M CERTAIN WHEN SHE IS NOT
CERTAIN.
SHE IS SAYING I’M NOT CLEARLY
I WAS DRINKING.
SO I THINK THAT IS PRETTY
STRAIGHTFORWARD.
RONIN FARROW SAYS HE CONSIDERS
WHAT HE DID HIGH LEVEL OF
EVIDENCE.
I’M QUOTING.
AND SAYS THAT DIRECT ACCOUNT
FROM PEOPLE SHE TOLD RIGHT
AFTERWARD THIS HAPPENED WITH
KAVANAUGH.
THAT IS WHAT FARROW SAYS.
HE SAYS HE APPLIED THAT IN
OTHER STORIES OF SIMILAR
INSTANCES OF SEXUAL MISCONDUCT
AND SAYS IT HAS PROVEN TO BE
IRONCLAD AND A GOOD WAY TO DO
IT AND HE CONSIDERS THIS IS A
HIGH STANDARD OF JOURNALISM.
>> Jesse: I DIDN’T KNOW THAT
IS THE WAY HE WENT ABOUT IT.
THOUGHT HE FOUND SOMEONE WHO
HEARD SOMETHING LIKE THAT HAD
HAPPENED.
NOT THAT THIS WOMAN HAD TOLD A
FRIEND ABOUT IT AFTERWARDS.
>> Lisa: THE PIECE SAYS THEY
HAVE NOT CONFIRMED WITH OTHER
EYEWITNESSES THAT KAVANAUGH
WAS PRESENT AT THE PARTY.
THE "NEW YORK TIMES" REACHED
OUT TO SEVERAL DOZEN
INDIVIDUALS TRYING TO
CORROBORATE THE STORY AND
COULD.
NO AND EVEN REPORTED THAT
RAMIREZ HERSELF WAS CALLING TO
ASK IF THEY COULD RECALL THIS
FROM HAPPENING.
THIS IS PRETTY CLEAR TO
EVERYONE WHAT IS GOING ON NOW.
THE #MeToo MOVEMENT CREATED
AN ENVIRONMENT WHERE WE ARE
COERCED TO SIMPLY BELIEVE A
WOMAN BECAUSE OF HER GENDER.
DEMOCRATS ARE TAKING
ADVANTAGE, MANIPULATING THAT
ENVIRONMENT.
AND NOW WEAPONIZING THE
UNCORROBORATED ACCUSATIONS AS
A POLITICAL TOOL TO CLOBBER
JUDGE KAVANAUGH WITH.
IT’S DISINGENUOUS AND
DANGEROUS.
FRANKLY, THE "NEW YORKER"
SHOULD BE ASHAMED THEY RAN THE
STORY TO BEGIN WITH.
>> Jesse: GREG, IF YOU LOOK
BACK TO THE WEEKEND.
ONE OF THE ALLEGED WITNESSES
WITH DR. FORD, FEMALE, GOOD
FRIEND, CAME OUT AND SAID I
NEVER HEARD OF THIS.
NOT SURE ABOUT THE PARTY.
DON’T KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT
THIS.
THEN YOU HAVE A SECOND AD
VICTIM COME OUT -- ALLEGED
VICTIM COME OUT.
WHAT DOES THE PATTERN TELL YOU
NOW?
>> Greg: DIANNE FEINSTEIN
COULD RUN AN AIRLINE WITH THAT
KIND OF TIMING.
I WAS PERFECTLY TIMED.
YOU HAVE A LONG-TIME FRIEND,
FOURTH PERSON IN THE STORY
WITH NO RECOLLECTION.
BOOM!
IT WAS A SATURDAY.
SUNDAY YOU HAD NEW ACCUSATION.
WHAT WORRIES ME IN THE BIG
PICTURE WE ARE SHIFTING THE
MEANING OF THE WORD
"CORROBORATION" BEFORE AN
ACCUSATION WOULD REQUIRE
COLLABORATION, WHICH MEANT
WITNESSES AND EVIDENCE WHICH
THE FORD CASE SEEMED TO LOOK.
NOW THIS OTHER ONE SEEMS
WEAKER THAN FORD.
SO YOU CORROBORATE ONE
ALLEGATION WITH WHAT?
ANOTHER ALLEGATION.
SO WHAT HAPPENS IS THE MEDIA
IS LESS INCLINED TO DIVE DEEP
IN THE STORY.
INSTEAD JUST PILE WELL, IT
MUST HAVE HAPPENED BECAUSE NOW
IT’S QUANTITY NOT QUALITY.
>> THERE IS AN ADDITIONAL
POINT.
I HAVE NEVER SEEN ANYTHING
LIKE THIS IN MY CAREER OVER
THREE DECADES.
I’VE NEVER SEEN SO MANY
REPRESSED MEMORY CASES IN MY
LIFE.
ESPECIALLY AGAINST ONE GUY.
>> Greg: YEAH.
>> SO THE QUESTION IS, IF
THERE IS SOMETHING AWRY GOING
ON, WAS THERE HYPNOSIS?
ARE THEY USING CONFABLATION?
I DON’T WANT TO GET IN THE
WEEDS HERE.
BUT THIS IS THE THING THEY
HAVE A RIGHT TO TRUE CROSS
EXAMINATION.
THE DEMOCRATS DON’T WANT TRUE
CROSS EXAMINATION.
THEY WANT KAVANAUGH TO GO
FIRST.
HOW DOES THE DEFENDANT OR THE
ACCUSED GO FIRST WHEN HE
DOESN’T KNOW WHAT THE
ACCUSATION IS?
HOW IS IT THE DEFENDANT ABLE
TO REBUT AND PRESENT A DEFENSE
WHEN THE COMPLAINING WITNESS
DOESN’T GIVE A BILL OF
PARTICULARS AS TO WHAT
HAPPENED?
I MEAN THIS IS SO BACKWARDS.
IT’S SO OBVIOUSLY AN
ATTEMPT --
>> Juan: LET’S GO WITH WHAT
YOU ARE SAYING.
>> GOOD.
>> Juan: LET’S HAVE THE
F.B.I. --
>> SHE IS OKAY WITH THAT.
>> Juan: HAVE THE F.B.I.
COME IN AND SAY HERE IS A FACT
BASIS THAT WE CAN ALL AGREE
ON.
AND THAT IS WHAT THEY ARE
CALLING FOR.
>> SO LET ME ASK YOU THIS,
JUAN.
>> Juan: NO, LET ME JUST
SAY.
YOU HAVE A SITUATION HERE
WHERE YOU JUST DESCRIBED,
JUDGE, ONE SET OF FACTS FROM
ONE PERSON AND ANOTHER SET OF
FACTS FROM ANOTHER.
AND THEN SHE SAYS THE PARTY
OCCURRED.
HE SAYS I WASN’T AT THAT
PARTY.
HE SAYS I DON’T KNOW WHEN THE
PARTY WAS.
HOW CAN HE DENY HE IS AT A
PARTY SHE HASN’T IDENTIFIED?
>> FIRST, LET ME EXPLAIN
SOMETHING.
WHEN SHE SAYS SOMETHING, HE
HAS THE RIGHT TO KNOW
SPECIFICALLY WHAT IT IS.
>> Juan: OKAY.
>> BUT IN THE END, THERE IS NO
WAY YOU CAN EVEN CONSIDER
BRINGING IN THE F.B.I.
MY QUESTION TO YOU IS A SIMPLE
ONE.
EVERYBODY IS TALKING ABOUT
LET’S BRING IN THE F.B.I.
WHY THE HELL HAVEN’T YOU ASKED
THE F.B.I. TO GET INVOLVED?
WHY DID DIANNE FEINSTEIN SIT
ON THIS FOR SIX WEEKS?
WHY DID SHE SIT ON IT FOR 36
YEARS?
>> Juan: IT WAS ANONYMOUS.
>> IT WAS.
NO THEY KNEW WHO SHE
WEDNESDAY.
>> Juan: -- WHO SHE WAS.
>> Juan: SHE WAS ANONYMOUS.
THIS IS SOMETHING YOU ASKED
ABOUT.
IN THIS CASE, WHEN SOMEONE IS
NOMINATED FOR THE SUPREME
COURT AND SUDDENLY YOU HAVE
ALL THE WORLD’S EYEBALLS FIXED
ON THIS GUY.
NOW THEY ARE GOING TO FLY
SPECK HIM.
I DON’T CARE WHO YOU ARE.
THAT IS A FACT.
SO SUDDENLY A LOT OF PEOPLE
WHO KNEW HIM AND HAD
QUESTIONS.
REMEMBER, IN THE SECOND CASE,
THAT WOMAN WASN’T COMING
FORWARD.
THE WOMAN AT YALE.
>> HOW DID THEY FIND HER?
>> Juan: THE DEMOCRAT HEARD
STORIES ABOUT --
>> WELL THEN WHERE IS THE COB
RATING -- CORROBORATING
WITNESS TO SAY THEY HEARD FROM
SOMEONE.
>> I’M WITH YOU, JUDGE.
BRING IN THE F.B.I. IN.
>> NO.
THE F.B.I. DOESN’T DO THESE
CASES.
THAT IS WHY THEY HAVEN’T
ANSWERED YES.
>> Juan: I’LL TELL YOU WHAT
IS INTERESTING GOING ON
TODAY --
>> THIS IS ALL CONFUSION AND
ALL --
>> Juan: NO, NO.
WHAT IS INTERESTING THAT
MARTHA MacCALLUM TONIGHT
IS GOING TO HAVE KAVANAUGH AND
HIS WIFE ON HER SHOW.
TO ME THIS IS LIKE WOW!
YOU MEAN A GUY WHO IS UP FOR A
SUPREME COURT NOMINATION
DECIDES IT’S IMPORTANT TO TAKE
A BREAK AND DO TV?
>> Jesse: I THINK HE IS
TRYING TO DEFEND HIMSELF.
>> Greg: WAIT, WAIT, WAIT.
YOU CAN’T SMEAR A GUY FROM
TRYING TO DEFEND HIMSELF.
>> Juan: I’M SAYING BOY, DID
YOU SEE THE FOX POLL?
THE FOX POLYPED KATES NOW MORE
PEOPLE BELIEVE FORD THAN
BELIEVE KAVANAUGH.
>> Greg: WHAT A SURPRISE
AFTER WHAT HAS BEEN DONE TO
HIM.
IF ALLEGATIONS ARE ENOUGH
WITHOUT WITNESS OR WITHOUT
EVIDENCE, YOU SHOULD WORRY
ABOUT YOUR HUSBANDS, YOUR
BROTHERS, YOUR SONS AND YOUR
FATHERS.
>> AND YOURSELF.
>> Greg: THERE NEEDS TO BE A
NEW WOMAN MOVEMENT CALLED
MOMMA BEAR BECAUSE THEY ARE
COMING FOR YOUR SONS.
>> CAN YOU BE PART OF IT IF
YOU ARE NOT A MOM?
DON’T EXCLUDE ME, GREG.
>> Greg: WHAT IS GOING TO
HAPPEN IS BECAUSE YOU CAN’T
NOMINATE MEN ANYMORE?
YOU KNOW WHO IS THE SUPREME
COURT JUSTICE?
JUDGE PIRRO.
>> NOT A CHANCE!
LET ME TELL YOU, ALL I’D LIKE
TO DO IS QUESTION THE TWO OF
THEM.
THAT IS ALL I WANT TO DO.
>> Jesse: MORE PROOF THAT
THE FACTS ON KAVANAUGH DON’T
MATTER TO DEMOCRATS.
THE LATEST LEFT WING SMEAR
AHEAD.